[Music]
the Empire's building a weapon capable
of destroying an entire planet we have
to capture the plans if there's any hope
of destroying it
how many do any make 10 men see like a
hundred
welcome to rogue one
if the Empire has this kind of power
what chance do we have
rebellions are built on hug
[Music]
Jenny whatever I do I'd like to protect
you
see understand dream state
[Music]
we have intercepted a coded Imperial
transmission it indicates that a major
weapons test is imminent we need to know
how to destroy it so why me the message
was sent by your father they call it the
death toll it's capable of destroying an
entire planet it could be the end of us
as a way to defeat him you need to
capture the time
you're really doing this I want to help
we'll need a team
she wants to fight
Yan was shocked me know welcome
power that we are dealing
immeasurable
there is a 97.6% chance of failure
I'll go shuttle what's your callsign
it's um Rogue rogue one they've no idea
we're coming
make 10 men see like a hundred
just take the next chance
next
until we win the return Cesare spent
there was a ninety-seven point six
percent chance of failure